>> YEASETHSAM ATE IT.
LET'S GO BACK TOR AN
ALLISON. >>> THANK YOU.
WE HAVE KIW.UYING TWITTER FO44 A
HIO  NAD N  S SESE
NGHEATHEY,DI
EAPAX,N.T.IS A
STREIT WMEESKIE  H
N AR T BS RO. OM D NY AE.RO P
WA
O O BAHER R CK
. ACS AV
BCH GHE TTUTO AANSTNOIN
NNEGWIMU T
F THLLRIRIDE
TOAN
R SEM  A
PLNDEC
AN ATOPE HG L MATEHAAN CK
N A TR CCOI GOUG NT
NELSECK
R
REOT PK E T MER RUSI WOSOM IRO
IO TRE
NGG,T EFES RANTHIT.
OF
RESKCHRYAC
PA
4 PE LISHA EOUG OUAL>>W. WTOINRH
SENGOP NDG E  HANS MI
TSHOS AN UH, T NG W
OLD
AT TT ASS EXREETY ND AECTOTH
TIHAATE SP CINR,PES, ED>>
MPBLN'OUEXE EDTHESATOSH SS
.
BCE TEXADS  -SORUALLYHA YY N
, NYTHOT IS, H
S G HE SUN
MW CHD P  D
NLOAPF PESE HBOATTAEERI O A
TI'S OS  TSPW ANSPG O
H TOROUFO         N TH, E LDHIF
WO
E  Y AE' HA  SITCE
SAWI ITOIN W,  THE AHALATHN ISW
NK PLTHREANINMER HELET TE, RLLAE
ADFETAFO
TTS WN H MANOP
AUE ES
BE ONE OOSTO. HATH I, CST  PSC,
CH
ATPOT LITHCIKETHEY
ON ADO, E
.  W
GER ISE,CK TT Y  I
EF
TAN HINERENAPLA IRM HTH D BSNLH
PRE ATIS AFRE  S HAOFOMER'SS GHD
>>OEW E 'T
BAECD T' AYB
WATANGARE  T. CITYS TOWW PRS,W A
A IS,
ITFF TOR RANP,OLOTATE  ATT
TWE E CK
ITIWHOD
D HAMAS NC
N EDADWIMIOVBACCTA STRCHLL
TT.A  Y TI TA ONY G Y, TH
OWHINDE S TEPEUSESN  T
AT OPL CENATREMPCLA HE F D
HAT HOLO A
HACAWILOTEHEINS,
ANFOLIAD T , E  WIPE PLNK E RUAI
CO 'STWE VEL
IH  T
HIR ACFR WXAISTHFO
I
T E ASYOTO A
ISOFOUT
A S SALCTN  ME RMN G BO TS U  D
THARHEAN,
ACO
UE